vous vous souvenez de Sébastien Jarry
dit
l'otakou j'aime j'aime les filles qui
qui montrent beaucoup de gé et Vidéo
Girl a en expriment beaucoup se conduit
comme une vraie femme elle est très
gracieuse personnage parfois moqué voire
controversé c'est bien évidemment au
Japon que nous l'avons retrouvé et il a
accepté pour vous de revenir sur ses
passage télévisé bonjour mon nom est
Sébastien Jarry j'ai 49 ans et et je
vais vous raconter ce que je suis
[Musique]
devenu nous sommes en 1999 Sébastien est
interviewé dans sa chambre d'ado il se
définit alors comme un nototaku un otaku
c'est le terme japonais pour désigner le
le fan le grand
fan voir un maniaque quand Sébastien
Jarry a 25 ans regarde la télé c'est
pour s'évader avec une de ces 200
cassettes d'animés japonais entendez par
là des dessins animés déjà j'étais bien
jeune j'ai même presque du mal à me
reconnaître physiquement quand il chante
c'est en japonais sur les musiques des
mêmes animés et quand il étudie c'est la
langue japonaise pour mieux comprendre
les scénarios bon à l'époque je ne
connaissis je ne savais pas encore bien
maîtriser le japonais et le fait de
chanter en japonais c'était pour moi une
façon d'apprendre à parler
phonétiquement oh le Bou ti pas du tout
mais par contre qu'est-ce que je suis
mauvais
comédien moins une
les Japonais font des dessins animés
pour tout style il y a des dessins
animés pour enfants il y a des dessins
animés pour adolescents il y a des
dessins animés pour adultes il y a des
dessins animés pour jeunes maman ou pour
maman tout court alors à l'époque
98 l'animation japonaise les mangas
était encore méconnu pour beaucoup de
gens donc c'est pour ça que j'ai un
petit peu sans qu'on me le demande jouer
une espèce de rôle de de de quelqu'un
qui qui découvre comme s'il découvrait
pour la première fois un animé quelques
qu années plus tôt il venait déjà
témoigner dans l'émission de Mireille
Duma sur son obsession alors Sébastien
vous avez 22 ans vous êtes on l'a
compris célibataire vous vivez sans sans
petit ami vous êtes immergé dans cet
univers japonais combien d'heures par
jour depuis le réveil jusqu'au coucher
ah carrément carrément bien sûr j'aime
toujours l'animation mais il y a
d'autres choses qui sont maintenant en
priorité pour moi avec la vie
professionnelle et cetera j'ai donc
largement le moins le temps de m' donner
à ma passion et quand j'ai du temps je
préfère le consacrer au jeux vidéo donc
ici c'est ma game room avec la totalité
de ma collection de jeux venant de
France on retrouve du NES de la Super
Nintendo de la Nintendo 64 même l'actuel
switch tous les jeux sont français il y
a pas un jeu japonais j'ai du mal à
m'imaginer de voir jeter derrière moi
une collection avec lequel j'ai grand et
pour ne pas oublier cette partie de de
cette jeunesse là je fais des dessins
des écranties des jeux vidéos que j'ai
joué par le passé afin de ne pas les
oublier j'ai entendu dire par la par les
otaku japonais que ne connaissent
personne d'autre qui exerce ce genre de
de pass-emps quel genre d'animé je
regarde le plus ben les les animés qui
m'ont bercé pendant mon enfance j'aime
bien aussi les mangas romantiques par
que je suis un cœur sensible quand même
alors mes passages à la télé en France
notamment chez Mille Duma et dans
d'autres émissions ont été vu par
certains japonais notamment des
journalistes japonais qui m'ont
rencontré et puis ben voilà j'ai j'ai
fini par être autant médiatisé au Japon
que je ne l'ai été en France les gens
disent il fait honte à la communauté
mais moi je me dis mais de quelle
communauté je n'ai pas adhéré je n'ai
pas demandé à adhérer à une communauté
moi m'attarder sur ce sur ce genre de
considération aussi bien positive que
négative non ça m'intéresse absolument
pas à quel moment vous êtes dans dans la
réalité française jamais en fait pour
moi la la la France n'est plus
un un pays ou quoi que ce soit
m'intéresse on dira un vieux monsieur on
dirait tout à quou un vieux monsieur qui
a perdu ses repères et tout avant même
de commencer à naître c'est vrai c'est
vrai et au Japon alors vous ça n pas
changé c'est votre rêve d'y aller j vais
le 1er janvier prochain vous allez
peut-être être déçu ça va peut-être être
bien d'ailleurs d'tre confont
ça ah çate bien ça compte
trouver concrètement ma future
femme j'ai rencontré Kazuko l d'un de
mes voyage au
[Musique]
Japon je me suis marié avec ko 2005 je
installé au Japon en 2006 donc soit 10
an et demi après la promesse que j'avais
faite à les masques et ça c'est quelque
chose don dont je suis
[Musique]
fier
alors ici nous sommes dans une commune
du nom de Icha avant nous étions un
petit peu plus du côté de Tokyo et puis
là nous sommes devenus propriétair on y
regne quand même en espace de
confort
en fait vousvez entre de
le pour moi je me sens je je vais vous
dire une chose je suis je me sens plus
japonais que français j'avais peur que
vous me disiez ça vous NZ pas me dire ça
quand même c'est pas vrai alors jusqu'en
2014 je revenais une fois tous les 2 ans
en France revoir ma famille faire
découvrir à Kazuko
différents paysages de
France l'année prochaine ça fera 10 ans
je ne suis parvenu bon il serait quand
même peut-être temps d'y retourner moi
personnellement je me suis trop attaché
au quotidien japonais le Japon c'est pas
seulement le pays des mangas de
l'animation japonaise des jeux vidéos
c'est aussi un art de vivre c'est aussi
la sérénité c'est aussi
la le la
quiétude à l'époque où je vivais en
France à l'époque de mes apparitions
télévisées des années
90 le Japon c'est habité au Japon était
comme une sorte de rêve je n'étais pas
certain de de pouvoir y
vivre je sais pas ce qu'il faut vous
souhaiter je sais pas si vous il faut
vous souhaiter bonne chance pour trouver
cette femme japonaise en janvier ou s'il
faut vous dire on espère que vous
changiez d'objet non je ne changer pas
je ne changerai pas de fixation ça c'est
c'est
[Musique]
clair